over the past year we have shown that
vaccination is the key to beating covid
and that it works
the uk was the first country in the
world to administer a vaccine we deliver
the fastest rollout in europe and we've
begun the fastest booster camp at
campaign 2 with over half a million jabs
delivered yesterday alone and these
achievements
made possible by the extraordinary
efforts of our nhs including thousands
of gps and volunteer vaccinators
have literally saved countless lives and
livelihoods in this country but i need
to speak to you this evening
because i'm afraid we're now facing an
emergency in our battle with the new
variant omicron
and we must urgently reinforce our wall
of vaccine protection to keep our
friends and loved ones safe
earlier today the uk's four chief
medical officers raised the coveted
alert level to four
its second highest level
because of the evidence that omicron is
doubling here in the uk every two to
three days
and we know from bitter experience how
these exponential curves develop
no one should be in any doubt there is a
tidal wave of omicron coming and i'm
afraid it is now clear that two doses of
vaccine are simply not enough to give
the level of protection we all need
but the good news is that our scientists
are confident that with a third dose a
booster dose we can all bring our level
of protection back up
i know there will be some people
watching who will be asking
whether omicron is less severe than
previous
variants and whether we really need to
go out and get that booster and the
answer is yes we do
do not make the mistake of thinking
omicron can't hurt you can't make you
and your loved ones seriously ill
we've already seen hospitalizations
doubling in a week in south africa
and we have patients with omicron in
hospital here in the uk right now
at this point our scientists cannot say
that omicron is less severe and
even if that proved to be true
we already know it is so much more
transmissible that a wave of omicron
through a population that was not
boosted
would risk a level of hospitalization
that could overwhelm our nhs
and lead
sadly
to very many deaths
so
we must act now
today we're launching the omicron
emergency booster national mission
unlike anything we've done before in the
vaccination program
to get boosted now
a fortnight ago i said we would offer
every eligible adult
a booster by the end of january
today
in light of this omicron emergency i'm
bringing that target forward
by a whole month
everyone eligible aged 18 and over in
england will have the chance to get
their booster before the new year
and we've spoken today to the duval
administrations to confirm the uk
government will provide additional
support to accelerate vaccinations in
scotland wales and northern ireland to
hit the pace we need
we'll need to match the nhs's best
vaccination day so far and then beat
that day after day
this will require an extraordinary
effort and as we focus on boosters and
make this new target achievable it will
mean some other appointments will need
to be postponed until the new year
but if we don't do this now
the wave of omicron could be so big
that cancellations and disruptions like
the loss of of cancer appointments would
be even greater next year
and i know the pressures on everyone in
our nhs from our gps doctors nurses to
our porters all of whom have worked
incredibly hard and i thank you i thank
them for all the amazing work that
they've done but i say directly
to to those of you on the front line
i must ask you to make another
extraordinary effort now
so we can protect you and your
colleagues and above all protect your
patients from even greater pressures
next year
so from tomorrow in england we're
opening up the booster to every adult
over 18 who has had a second dose of the
vaccine at least three months ago
the nhs booking system will be open for
these younger age groups from wednesday
and that's the best way to guarantee
your slot
but in some places you can walk in from
tomorrow
we will also assist this emergency
operation by deploying 42 military
planning teams across every health
region standing up additional vaccine
sites and mobile units
extending opening hours so clinics are
open seven days a week with more
appointments early in the morning in the
evening and at weekends
training thousands more volunteer
vaccinators and will set out further
steps in the days ahead
it's because of the threat from omicron
that i announced on wednesday that we
will move to plan b in england you must
wear a face covering in indoor public
spaces and from tomorrow work from home
if you can and from wednesday subject to
a vote in parliament you'll need to show
a negative lateral flow test to get into
nightclubs and
some large events if you're not double
vaccinated
these measures will help slow the spread
of omicron but we must go further and
get boosted now
if you haven't yet had a vaccine at all
then please get yourself at least some
protection with a jab as quickly as
possible
if you've already had your booster
encourage your friends and family
to do the same
we're a great country we have the
vaccines to protect our people so let's
do it
let's get boosted now
get boosted now for yourself for your
friends and your family get boosted now
to protect jobs and livelihoods across
this country
get boosted now to protect our nhs
our freedoms and our way of life
get boosted now
thank you very much